Yeah.
Good morning. How are you? I'm fine. Great.
Ready for full day class,
Actually, your lab?
Yes, yes, yes. We can suggest, uh,
To suggest that Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can, um, back to back theory?
Yeah. Yes, correct. That is nice.
Let's suggest this actually, we can suggest here also,
or we can send, um, maybe or,
and the project meeting also, we can
Yes, Yes, yes. Request
actually.
So this will,
okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
Good morning to all. Good morning, sir.
Morning. Good morning, sir. Good morning.
Yeah, we'll start in just another one minute.
Yeah, sure, sir. Morning, sir. Good morning. Morning,
morning, sir.
Good morning.
All right. So let me share my screen now.
Okay.
So, uh, from ta, anyone is here, Vimal
or, uh, who else?
Uh, Vimal. Are you there?
Okay, This, they have not joined. No problem.
Last class, uh, uh, the slides, uh,
I guess the recording must be available,
but slides we could not upload,
but now we have TAs are in place for this course.
Maybe today, after the class, we'll upload whatever we,
So, And just to recap
what we did in the last class.
Yeah. So, uh,
Uh, First of all, yeah, please.
Sorry to, can we increase the time period for us, uh,
submitting summary, because half a little bit, uh,
it time, sir?
Um, how much time? Oh, half an hour. It is given, so yes.
How much, how much time You want us to increase?
Minimum One hour, sir. Okay, we'll do that. No problem.
Thank you, sir. Um, sir, I think, uh,
with the personal survey we discussed that it has
to be 24 hours,
24 hours summary.
Yeah. Okay. Because some people who are joining late
or recordings,
Ika, no problem. Sarah
has told already. We'll do that.
No problem. I think that will help.
Thank you. Okay, sure.
Okay. So, uh, uh, in the last class, first of all, we, uh,
went through the course plan
and we understood what are the different topics which we are
going to cover in this particular course.
And then, sir, had given some very high level overview
of machine learning, deep learning, ai, LL, M and all,
and find, uh, and then in the second part of the class,
we talked about the pieto.
Because we mentioned this point that we want
to keep this course as 50, 50%, 50% theory, where math
and conceptual understanding you will get,
and 50% we want you to do the practice also,
because that is what going
to help you immediately in your project as well
as whatever work you do in your workplace.
So that's why that was the idea.
And, uh, we discussed a little bit why, uh, PyTorch,
why not TensorFlow, what, where they are,
uh, similar, what is the differences, okay?
And where they are being used.
So then we were talking about the different type of,
because in the tens, uh, tensor flow
or PyTorch, the role
of tensors are very important to understand.
The tensor, to visualize the tensors
are very, very important.
And we say that the sensor has nothing different than
MPI array, and all of you must have used the mpi,
but the difference comes when you go
with the higher dimensions.
So when you see the, uh, one dimension
or zero dimension, like a scaler
or one dimension, like a vector
or two dimension, like a metrics
or even the three dimensions, like three metrics on a stack,
uh, stack on each other, it,
it is almost similar to the mpi.
There is no difference. Also, it's very difficult
to identify the difference.
But when it goes to the four dimension, when it goes
to the five dimension, that is where the tensors comes
with the, uh, comes with the advantage that it is very easy
to represent the higher dimensions with the tensors.
That was one benefit. What we understood with the tensors,
the other benefit was that tensors are compatible
with the GPUs, which the conventional umpire,
uh, was not.
I mean, you can use it,
but then the,
the way the tens are designed at the GPUs are designed.
I mean, they, they co they complement each other.
And that's how we are able to do the
parallelization in the process, which is very important
for the neural networks point of view,
which were not important for other
conventional machine learning.
Fine. So there, these were some of the reasons, uh,
why this, this particular library pipe towards the tensor
flow was given only for the deep learning.
Okay? That was, that was one of the most important.
But, and, uh, yeah, we talked about this where
and all tensor are useful.
And, uh, finally, uh, yeah,
so these are some of the slide.
So everywhere in the deep learning we talked, we are going
to utilize the tens, whether it is a forward propagation
or there will be backward propagation
because these two are the, uh,
these two are the main algorithms, which will be true
for any kind of neural network architecture.
What you're going to learn in deep learning,
forward propagation will be there and backward propagation.
And there we can, we are going to utilize the tens.
So now finally, we stopped at this slide,
although we could not cover the demo in the last class,
but today we are going to start exactly from here.
That, uh, I'm going to open this link, uh, in fact, uh,
create a new collab for you.
And I'm going to type for you that,
and with, with together, we are going
to see some basics of the tens.
Some of you might be familiar with that.
So maybe it'll be just a revision for you.
And those who are starting first time with the tens, this,
this, uh, this, uh, this, uh, class is very important,
I would say, because this will give you the, some
of the very basics, which will be easy to understand as well
as, uh, you will get to know some of the tricks
and some not tricks means some of the functions
and, uh, some of the huge cases that where to use
what kind of things in the tens, fine.
So that, that is the whole intention.
So although this, this is available, whatever I'm going
to type is available with this demo link.
So if you will, uh, click, I'll upload this one soon
after this class, you will get the same collab,
but I'm going to type it for you one by one, okay?
The same thing, so that you'll have better understanding.
So I'll switch back to my, another, uh, another.
So here collab.
So I will, I'm opening the new collab notebook.
Stop me if somewhere you find there is any, anything.
You can also type it along with me if you wish, right?
But then as we mentioned in the last class, I will go ahead
and, uh, you always have the, uh, notebook available
with you after the class to do the practice by yourself.
Okay? So say I give the name as 10 basics.
So first part is always, uh, all of you're clear that, uh,
how to use the collab, which we are not going
to discuss again and again, why to use the collab,
because tensor, uh, the library is
by default installed with the collab notebook,
although we can do it with the con or vs code,
but then not preferring, um, so far that one
because, so for me, uh,
sharing this collab notebook is easier.
And even for you further, going further writing the
code in pythons and sharing in the collab will be easier.
So that's why we are still following.
We'll see that if it is required to change the, um,
environment, we'll see that later.
But I think for this course, this is sufficient, obviously,
uh, when you will go forward, uh, in the sense of, in
next semester, if, suppose you have a course called large
language model there, we'll see, most
of the time we need some ID where we have
to write the complete code.
I mean, collab may not be a good choice there in all the
click in all the cases,
but we'll see then, um, not now, now a couple of more things
that, uh, anyway, this we have to connect
and, uh, let me just show you.
Uh, so what we have to do is we, if you want to start
with the tensor flow, uh, we have
to import this library called torch.
This is the first thing what we have to do,
like we have been doing for other kind of library, we have
to import this one, okay?
So I'll import this torch,
and immediately I want to see something like, uh,
uh, I want to see what is the version
of this storage, which I'm using.
Okay? So I use torch dot,
then I will use this, uh, version,
this one, okay?
So it is giving a lot of suggestions
because it is already installed with a con.
As you will type, it'll also give you the suggestions.
So I'll start with this
and, uh, see this, uh, first time
manual import, it may take, uh, time.
Uh, yeah, so now you see that
to is already there in the collab.
That's the proof of it, because we are using now to 0.9 0.0.
This is the version of the tots,
which we are going to use right now.
Now, there is one more thing you must have observed that,
uh, there was something like, yeah, this,
this particular code, what you're seeing on the screen,
that it is like tots.coda.is available.
Okay, I'll just put a tab.
Use the complete code, and what is this particular code?
It is telling that whether the GPU is available with us
or not, because as I said, that, uh, in deep learnings,
GPU availability, uh, matters a lot.
Okay? I, and I'll show you the difference that
what happens if we use the CPU
and how much time difference it makes when we use the
GPU, right?
So GPU having the GPU is very important,
but then many times you don't know if suppose, uh, whether,
whether you are using the GPU, you don't know.
So this is the code with which you can first check that,
whether in your system
or the cloud environment, whatever you're using,
GPU is available or not.
If it is available, then you can set it to the GPU,
you can set it to the GPU so
that whatever processing you will do,
it'll happen with the GPU.
Otherwise it will take more time.
And there is a huge difference in time, huge difference
that I'm, I, I will show you at the last of this, the demo
as well with some operations.
We, we will do some metrics operation
and we'll see that how much time it takes with the CPU
and how much time the same operation takes with the GPU.
So that's how we'll try to get some, some insight on, on it.
So let me run this one.
And now it is saying that could I is not available.
Could I, uh, when say that it is not available,
that means GPU is not available, okay?
So, uh, although in the collab, you have the options
of the G-P-U-C-P-U both.
So what you can do is that runtime as well of, you know,
you can go and change the runtime.
So by default it is set as CPU.
So instead that kuda is not available,
but if I set it to the GPU, then I can use whatever,
uh, resource for the GPU.
It is I think Tesla T four.
That is what is available with this G uh, with this GPU
and that we can use it.
So as soon I will change the runtime, uh,
session will change that, you know, already.
So I will again import this line
and then I will try to run this line.
Now it is saying that Kodi is available.
So I will set it on this right now,
and we'll see that later.
We'll, we'll try to run on the GPU,
although we are not going to do any, uh, we are not going
to write any code, which requires today GPU,
except the last one where I, where I want
to show you the C-P-U-G-P-U difference,
but then also let it be on the, uh, GP.
So, um, that is one thing.
Now, uh, let us start with something for example,
because now we need to understand, uh,
that about more about the tensors.
So the first thing, what we can start with, uh, say
that creating tensor, this is, this is the first thing,
but we'll start with, okay, creating tensor.
So there are different ways of creating the tensors.
We are going to start one way.
And so first of all, what we'll use is we are going
to use the torch, which we have already imported at top,
and we'll say torch dot.
So this is the first way.
I mean, you can write the tensor by your own.
So you can write tensor, okay?
And you can, you can decide whether you want, uh,
zero dimension tensor, one dimension tensor,
or two dimension tensor, what, what exactly you want, right?
So whatever you want, you can actually type it
and you can, uh, get it.
For example, I want two dimension tenor.
So I need this kind of, uh, uh, like list
of list which will represent, it is going to be the
two dimension tenor, and I can type whatever I
want, whatever elements I want.
And as you know, that you're allowed to write even the, uh,
in teaser number here,
or the float number here, whatever you want.
Okay? So say that. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
This is the, this is what I want to create as a tenor,
and I will just keep it, uh, I will just, uh, save it in,
say a, this is one of the tensor which I want to create,
and then I'm going to print it.
So yeah, that's all. So as you can see here, it looks like,
uh, array, MPA array, right?
So at the, if you would've used mpa, it would've,
it would've told it is a MPA array,
but now it is saying that it is a tensor.
So yes, it is same as MPI array.
They said it's nothing different than MPA array.
But yes, when going to the end dimension,
tensors are more flexible
and easy to use as compared to the MPI array, right?
All the metrics of implementations
and all you can do in parallel with the GPU,
which is difficult with the NumPy array.
So that is the main difference in the look and feel.
It'll give you like you're using the GPU. Okay?
Nothing, nothing different, okay? That is one thing.
Now, uh, you can use many other type of, uh,
uh, tensor.
When you want to create, for example,
there is something called torch, torch dot empty.
You can use torch dot empty.
Uh, it's not giving the suggestion,
but you can use tots empty,
and you can decide, okay, what is the size of the array?
What I need, for example, uh, say that, uh, it is B
in which I'm storing this particular tensor,
and if I run, it'll, it'll show,
it'll give the output like this.
Now, what does it mean? You can see that there are two rows.
There are two rows here, first row and second row,
and there are three columns.
Fine. In this particular, that's why I have,
I have given the size, size of the tensor, which I want,
but then you can also see there are some numbers
which I never initialized.
Okay? I said that, okay, I need to cross three tensor,
and I said that it should be empty.
But then what I am getting as a return is a,
is some number it in the two cross, three tensor.
So what you have to understand by it is
that when you say the stores dot empty two,
cross three in the memory,
consider you're using the ram fine in the memory two,
cross three, whatever size is required, uh, say
that it is by default float.
Then for float, suppose you required eight byte,
then 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Okay? Six into eight.
Those many bytes would be assigned, okay?
Would be assigned somewhere in
the memory, somewhere in the memory.
We don't know that,
that we don't, we don't have any control.
But then wherever it is being given 48 bytes to us,
those locations have some number already.
Those locations have some number already
because maybe that space was used by some other programmer.
Clear possible, right?
Possible because ram is a shared memory,
like multiple programs uses the ram, ram, someone use it,
then freeze, uh, free that space so
that someone else can use that one, something like that.
So once this particular space is given to us,
or to be, there's already some numbers which is stored in
those locations.
And hence you can see these numbers.
We have never initialized these numbers
for this particular tensor,
but then you can see some numbers.
So you can treat these numbers as garbage.
You can see it as a garbage.
So it is not the number which you have ever in your slice.
So it is a garbage, that's all.
So you can always clean it
or you can replace it with some other number.
All those things are possible,
but this is one way you can create the empty tensor
of whatever size you want, okay?
Now, similarly you can do, uh, if, if this is a problem
and you feel that, oh, what is this number?
How to replace? And what you can do is instead of, uh,
creating the empty tensor, you can always create the tensors
of zeros, okay?
Tensors of zeros.
So I use the zeros and I'll give the same size. Okay?
I'll give the same size.
So let us see now what will happen instead
of giving these garbage value, now, it'll give me zero.
So now I, what I'm doing is I'm creating the tensor two
cross three, but at the same time also initializing.
So creation and initialization,
there are two operation which is happening
with this particular function when I'm calling
with the touch, okay?
Simple and everything looks like look
and feel is just like an area, nothing different.
Now, similarly, you can do extended for to one cell.
So there are some more functions like that, which, uh,
will help you to, uh, start creating the tens for some,
some use cases if you wish.
Okay? So suppose now I am, I want to create, I want
to put all the ones so I can go ahead with towards dot ones.
No, you can also do something like that towards dot,
something called ran.
Okay? So now what it'll do is say that two cross three,
and I'm now storing it in E, okay?
Just a second. Yeah.
So E, so now what it,
what is happening is it has this particular function,
if you will go and search docu, see the documentation, it,
it, it is like, uh, it,
it give you the randomly distribution with a means zero
and a standard deviation one.
That means that it randomly assigns the value between zero
and one simple, okay?
It, this particular function randomly assigns the value
between zero and one, and how many values I have to, uh,
how many such random value I have to create to cross three.
This is the structure means total six values,
having the two rows and three columns.
And that's why you can see that all the numbers here are in
between zero and one.
Okay? So that is how you can, uh, uh, create a tensor
of any size, obviously two across three, I'm showing you.
But you can create any like 10 across 10.
That is also, it'll create, that's not a problem, right?
So, uh, now this, this particular, this particular,
uh, function, uh,
would be very helpful when we will build the neural
networks, because what happens in the neural network,
and most of you know now that we have the number
of layers in the neural network, we have input layer,
we have, uh, hidden layer, we have output layer,
and these layers are connected via weights,
and we need to train those weights in order
to get whatever output we want
for whatever work we are doing, right?
So when we start training,
when we start training those neural network,
we initialize those weights randomly,
we initialize those weights randomly.
Now, when we have to initialize those weight weights
randomly, we need to, we always go ahead
with some range in which we want
to initialize those weights.
We can go it with a ian distribution,
that all the weights will be between zero
and one like this, what you are seeing on the screen.
Or I can also go it with some other distribution, like, uh,
say uniform distribution, and I can give the range
or I can go with, with some other distribution as well.
But then mostly what we do, we go ahead with this, uh,
causing distribution with this, uh, standard deviation,
one means zero, and we initialize all those weights.
And then obviously there is a back propagation happens,
update ation of those weights happen, that will learn later
some of the clue you might be having.
But yes, this is the good way.
So that's why these, these functions are very helpful in the
initial phase of the weight initialization, right?
So that we are going to use later part
of the, uh, course also.
So you will see that one.
So this is, uh, one function with which you can create the,
uh, you can say that the, uh, uh, tensiles with a,
with a sum, sum random distribution
with the distribution, fine.
Now, there is one thing. Now, uh, there is, uh, so
although we have talked about it earlier, in the case
of the machine learning, uh, machine learning,
we had a concept of seed value.
We have a concept of seed value, if you can recall.
So what we were doing that, uh, if you can recall that, uh,
in the machine learning, we were using the train test split
function, at least there, we have used this part
and we were dividing our data set into, uh, uh,
suppose training and testing say this is a task.
Now, while dividing our data set into training
and testing, we always want to shuffle the data.
We don't want to take the serial wise data into training
or testing that may create the bias
because it may happen that, okay, one class
of data serially, it is written, another class
of data is coming after that, then what will happen?
Only one class of data may go into training
or testing, right?
Which is not good for the model.
So what we do, we first shuffle the data
and then we pick whatever percentage of data we want to keep
for train or test.
But when we are choosing, uh, we do choosing the data
randomly, we had to keep that in one thing in mind,
that every time when we run that code, this randomly picking
may harm or may show the,
may show the differences in the accuracy.
Because every time we are going to pick the data,
and that is random, and every time the data is being
different at the training time, we lead
to the different accuracy of the model, right?
So what we did, we set a seed value.
We said that randomness is important, shuffling
of the data is important,
and then picking the random data is important,
but at the same time, we should control this randomness
by some means, by some, some way,
otherwise reproducing the code would be difficult.
It is very difficult to reproduce the code.
And that's where this manual sheet is, is,
is we had helped us,
and now the same thing we are going to do, we are going
to use this manual seed, uh, yeah, this manual seed,
and we can set any value, whatever you want, say
that 10, okay?
So that, okay, before that, let me just show you,
if we don't, if we don't, uh, uh,
put this manual sheet, what will happen?
Yeah. So you see this, the same, same lines
of code when I have run it for two times, giving different,
different values.
Now, this is what I was talking about.
If you don't control this randomness, any value between zero
and one can be assigned to those weights.
If weights value is different, obviously output,
what you're going to get is different
because your neural network is completely relying on these
weights, right?
So that's, that's a problem.
Or you can say that, yeah, whatever it, it happens,
doesn't matter because we are going
to train it these weights, back propagation and all.
But the difference will come if support these weights are
like this, you, your model may get converged.
Say that in five EPOCs
and ippo, these are the set of weights
with which you're initializing your neural network.
It may take 10 EPOCs.
Now that's where the difference may come.
You may end up with the same accuracy,
but then, uh, this is the difference.
You may definitely see that, okay, some, sometimes
for the same neural networks, same data,
you take only five hydrations to train it,
but sometimes it is taking 10 ations,
sometime it is taking only two ations.
Now, this is the variance, which we don't want to see.
We want to reproduce the code, however, number of times
or whoever will run that one.
So in such cases, this manual sheets are very important.
So now I have set this manual seeds,
and now let me just copy this line again.
Okay. So with this, now I am just, when,
when I'm running this one, then I will just, uh,
to use this, you see this one.
So now it has given me some value,
but I'll try to run this one with the same seed value.
Again, it is giving me the same set of value,
although it is random, but it is giving the same set of,
but this is what I was talking about,
which is very important while, uh, weight initialization.
So you, your weight should not change every time, right?
Uh, whenever you will start training
or reproducing your code, okay?
So this is also one, one thing.
What you have to keep in the mic,
and we'll do all these things, uh, once we'll work
with the neural network.
Now, there are some other ways also you can create the tens.
For example, you can use the store, store arrange, uh,
arrange, no, this is what it is showing on the screen.
You can use this one. So, uh, uh, I will
not use reshape reshape, but I'll show you later.
But this arrange I can use for, what I can do is say
that I'm giving the, uh, this,
and I'll show you what is happening.
So basically this ar range function is w working like a, uh,
it, it takes two parameters, in fact three parameters,
but here two is shown what is from where you want to start,
where you want to end, okay?
And what are the steps are.
So here you can clearly see
that we are starting at zero, going up to nine.
But many times when you will write the code,
and if you want to do any kind of iteration like loops
and all these range function
or arrange, eh, um, function will be helpful, right?
And obviously here you can see that the step size is one.
So it is giving every value between zero
and nine, but not 10.
So 10 is the stopping point, okay?
Now, if I put the step size two,
then you will get every alternate value, starting with zero
and stopping at 10.
So this is how, uh, this is quite simple.
You might be knowing that there another way
of creating the tensor called a storage line space.
So linear space means, uh, linearly a spaced.
So whatever range you are giving,
suppose you're giving the zero to start and 10 to stop,
and you're saying that I want
to create five linearly spaced values.
So this is the function which you can use.
So if you will run this one, you can see that.
So it has given five points between zero and 10.
It started with zero. The next one is 2.5, then five,
then 7.5, and then 10.
So if I'll say that I want 10 such hops
or uh, linearly spaced value, then this is how it'll be.
So whatever is the range, start
and stop in that how many, uh, that hops you want
to create, you can do with this one.
So this is another way of creating the tensors.
All these are tensors. Now basically I'm showing you only
the one dimensional tensor,
but you can always extend it for the higher dimension.
Uh, yeah. Then there is something called torch. Torch.
I, okay, torch I,
and you can, uh, simply say that, okay, what you, uh,
so dimension in which you want that identity operated.
So this is how the identity operator is given
where five cross five it is has created the, uh,
tensors fine.
So you can also create something called as, um,
uh, tots full.
Let me just show you torch, uh,
torch full.
So yeah, it has given some. So let us see what has happened.
So what you're saying
that you can create two cross three tensor means
two rows, three columns.
All the values are filled with five.
So if I'll change the value, it can fill all the values
by 10 or something like that.
So these are all the things in which,
or these are all the functions.
There are many other functions.
Also, I'm showing you some of them so that wherever you feel
that, oh, this might be helpful, you can utilize that.
Okay? So this is, this is, uh, some
of the things which you can use for creating the tens fine.
Now, if you have any query, you can ask me, otherwise.
Now I'll move to the next part.
That is called How to work with the Tensor.
Uh, this to ie, you have your means, uh,
it is like identity metrics,
Correct? Correct, correct.
It's an identity matrix. Yeah,
To dot hook and arrange.
What is the difference
To dot That This one sir?
Ah, yeah, line is space something similar, right?
Uh, it's similar, but then you see the differences.
Uh, when I see, when I put here two in the line
of space, what it is giving, okay?
And when I put here in the range, the same thing start
to stop and step size what it is giving.
So there is a difference. So it's, it's works like a it
range is like a giving you all the value between start
and stop with this step size common.
This line of space is creating the, uh, uh,
it's like linearly, a spaced value.
It is giving you between start and stop and how many,
however, how many value you
will say it'll give you that one.
So if I said two, only two value with,
but the linearly space, so yeah, linearly space is like,
you can say that it, it is, it works with a distance.
So when I said two, it is giving me zero, 10.
When I said five, then it is giving me five value,
but all are at the equal distance, zero to 2.5,
then 2.5 0.5 is five and so on.
Yeah. Got it. So yeah, yeah.
Okay. So I'm a very easy, it's not very big deal.
I understand, uh, uh, many of you must have done a lot
of things and lot more things like that,
but I, this is the first class,
so I thought I'll give you
the introduction of all those things.
Now we'll move on to the next part.
Suppose we have created the tensor sometime,
and now we need to know the shapes.
Uh, what is the shape of my tensor?
And going further, I'll show you how to
reshape those one if it is required,
because many times, reshaping of the tensor
and all that will, that will also will be required
when you will write the code.
So, uh, to start with, suppose we are starting, uh, uh,
we have used a, okay,
or let me just create one new tensor torch dot, uh, tensor
and say that I will use the same,
same tensor what I have used earlier.
So first one, then I'll use one word, okay?
So here I'm using 1, 2, 3, and here I'm using 4, 5, 6.
Okay? This is the tensile.
What I have, you see this and let me store it in X.
And now I want to know what is the shape,
although you can see that there are
two rows and three column.
But I want to know what is the function,
which can give you the same thing.
So here you can see that shape is the function like we have
used in the case of m and nothing different again.
But then shape is the function, which you can use to get
to know what is the size of your
tensor, which you have just created.
Uh, okay, that is one thing. Now, uh,
uh, with the shape, suppose I want to know the
data types and I want to change the data types sometimes.
No, this is important maybe.
So what what I can do is to this, uh,
XI want to know what is the data type, okay?
Because although it looks like it is in T,
but I want to confirm whether it is in T or not.
So what I'll do is X,
and then I will say dot D type, okay?
So it is saying that torch in teaser 64, so this,
so whatever te tensor it is created, it is using the teaser,
but 64 in, in inte also, you have the 64
bits in which you're representing the teaser
or inte 32, INTE 16, all those things are possible
and you can use it going further.
Uh, when you will learn about those, uh,
large language models where there are millions, trillions
of weights are available, people use the concept
of quantization and all.
There you will use this concept.
And these, these, these inte 64, inte 34 will mean a lot
to you, mean a lot to you, right?
So you can, and uh, the idea is to always, uh,
represent the same integer versus in 64 bits into 32 bits,
or even in the lower 16 bit
or eight bit, people have gone up to one bit also just
for your knowledge, because large language, modern survey,
difficult to handle, right?
So how to, how to quantize them into one bit.
So people have gone up to that level
and obviously there is a trade off between the size
and the performance, but then people are working around.
So that is the research which is going on.
So there, the data type, understanding
and all would be, uh, important too.
No. Now say that, uh, uh,
what I can do is, uh, I will just change this, uh,
same sensor say that what I'm doing is, uh,
okay, so, uh, instead of, uh,
using this, let me just use this, okay?
So I will use the storage 10, same thing,
what I have used, uh, add up.
But then now I am going to, uh, use this, uh, just
to show you that nothing different,
but just to show you that, okay, now one, 1.0 2.0
or 3.0 when I'm using,
and similarly, uh, 5.0
and, uh, uh, six
and seven, okay?
So then, uh, takes one positional, okay?
I have to put it in the two dimensions, right?
So yeah, now if you see that, what did it type?
So for that one, suppose I'm putting it in the
YD type, it is telling that float 32.
So it is a float number. Now,
why I have showed you this one, because now, uh, it is,
it is a float number.
And, and, uh, suppose what I want
to do is I want to do some change.
For example, uh, x I'll use this X, okay?
And add the zero and zero position.
Say that zero zero position is this one, right?
This one, one, this is zero zero, this is zero one,
this is zero two, this is 1 0 1, 1 and one two.
This is the, uh, index number in, in the 10 cells we choose.
So at the zero zero position,
suppose I want 2, 4, 5 0.0, okay?
It has done. Now, now I will just show you what is X dot
D type, okay?
Uh, five point in inte 0 62,
it has, okay?
Uh, so it is, it is, uh, what
what is happening is I will just, uh,
see, this is what I want to show.
See what happened. That initially when I created the
sensors, it was an in teaser type out,
and I have, we have confirmed it, the TAs interior 64 fine.
Similarly, if you create the, uh,
flow type, it'll show you that one.
But what I did is I just tried to modify that one
and manipulate the first, first element
and tried to store the float type.
Okay? So there is no, no problem.
Obviously there is no error.
So no problem, this line has executed.
But when I again checked that, what is its data type,
it's strategic 64,
but when I checked that, okay, what is the new element,
which is 5.5 has been replaced
with the first element one or not?
I'm seeing that no, it is just a five. It's not 5.5.
Now this is the difference. Yeah,
because your tensors are initialized with interiors type,
when you are trying to assign the float type,
it is not taking that one.
And obviously there is a type casting concept
where it trying to manage, not giving you there earlier
with the other programming language.
You might have seen like CC plus, which are not good
with this type casting or,
or, so it might have given you the error also that no,
you can, you have assigned the X as in teaser tenor,
but trying to assign the float value.
But Python has handled that, uh, that is exception, which,
and they handle it internally and do not show any error.
But these are the problems which you will see, uh, that, uh,
if, if it is not handled properly, it'll,
it'll give the error.
It'll give the error in some cases.
Now, I'll show you the cases
where it'll give the error, okay?
So it'll not give you the error directly by,
uh, type casting.
But then if, suppose you try
to do some mathematical operation, which we want to go, uh,
we want to see next mathematical operation with the tensor,
you will see that, okay?
What are the different kind of error you, uh,
that will give you the error.
So let us see that one first.
Mathematical operation as notator operations with
tensors, very important
because whole deep learning is the mathematical operations,
and there are two major operations
other than some other operation.
Two major operations are metrics, multiplication
and metrics edition.
Okay? So this is, this is one
of the most important operations,
what you would be seeing in every kind
of the neural network, at least when you do the
forward propagation.
Okay? So mathematical operation, let us first, uh,
use two different tensor.
So that X is my one tensor and Y is my another tensor.
These are the two tens I have.
And suppose I want
to do X plus Y, okay?
X plus Y. So obviously it'll add, there is no problem,
although X and Y is of different,
different types which we have already seen.
X is of type and TY is of type float.
But then obviously you can do the, uh, do the operation,
mathematical operation, which will intend float.
But good part what what I want to show you is how these two
mattresses or tensors are being added.
So just by adding, just by writing the plus sign,
it does everything, the, like that,
that's the nature of the python, right?
So python is so simple in that sense.
So, but how does it do?
It adds element wise, five plus one, six comes here,
two plus two, four comes here, three plus three six.
So you see that element wise edition is happening.
Similarly, you can do element wise multiplication. Okay?
So you can see that five four, so
how it is five into five is 5, 2, 2 2 is 4, 3, 2, 3 is six.
And likewise, uh, sorry, 3, 2, 3 is nine.
So that is what it is written here.
Similarly, you can do the subtraction also, okay?
Everything will work. You can do the division also, okay?
And you can do the division which always, uh,
store the inte value.
So that is also possible
and doesn't can, uh,
store the value versus coming after the decimal.
So double, uh, slash that is what you have to use,
or you can use the model as also.
So these are some of the famous mathematical operations,
which we will be using very frequently,
and you can see that very easily with the sensors.
You can execute it. There is no problem in that one.
Now, the problem which I wanted to show, uh, was, uh,
uh, okay, before that I have some, uh, few more things.
For example, suppose you have a torch.
Do tensor some more operations just for your understanding,
say that it is minus one, uh, minus two and three, okay?
And you are storing it in say, um, say that, uh, say
that F okay, this is the tensor,
and next line F this is the tensile what I have,
and there is something called torch a Bs.
So I just want to know the absolute value.
And you can see that, right? The negative can be converted
easily into the positive.
So these are some other things,
or what you can do is you can also convert torch dot.
So if I put C, so what it has done is, uh, sorry,
CYI have put, what is C oh, C was up, uh,
let me put F, C was C, we used it at up.
So what has happened is initial F value was minus one,
minus two that has been converted at plus one, plus two
and three was minus three.
So just negate whatever was the initial values. Okay?
All these things are simple. Now, uh,
there are a few more things.
What you can do is, uh, here say that I have a tensor,
tensor, uh, torch.
Sorry, first of all, torch I have to use then tensor,
and I'm using one dimensional, uh, tensor,
3.5 and uh, 6.9, okay?
And say that it is in Z and first, let me print that.
And now I will use some, some operations from the torch.
Like I can use it, I can use the operation like round. Okay?
So obviously you can, it'll round the value.
So to the nearest end, teaser one, 3.5 is four, 6.97.
Next value. But then you can always use torch, uh,
torch dot seal, okay?
Uh, seal function,
and again, give the G so you can see that.
So 1.2 is two, next gen is a value.
Two, 3.5 is four and seven, 6.97.
You can also use towards dot, uh, floor
to see the G.
So now you can see that it is like 1.2 is one, three,
0.5 is three, and 6.9 is six
will go to the left side, right?
Rather than going to the next.
So all these things are simple. You can, you can do that.
Just wanted to show that one.
Uh, sir, sir, can you just scroll up
This one? Yeah,
Yeah, sir. Uh,
in the torch, negative, right?
If you're doing to f, it is printing
as one, two, minus three.
But in the previous step it was storage, absolute.
It gave us one, two, and three.
So, so the point is I'm not storing
or replacing the F with whatever change I'm doing, okay?
If suppose I would've written here, f is equal
to that, okay?
Okay. Then it would've changed that like,
as you can see now, see this f
and here F is this 1, 2, 3.
And if I do now towards negative,
this is a minus one, minus two.
It has worked on this particular,
rather than working on
this, some of the things.
Alright, so now next thing which I want to show
is say some other operations.
See that tensor reduction that you have created a tensor
and now you want to reduce the tensor in some
other form, right?
For example, now say that you have, uh, uh, you have torch
to dot, uh, tensor, torch tensor,
or I will have say that ran ran two comma three.
This is a tensor what I have,
and I'm just trying to store, uh,
Uh, I'm trying to store it in some variable called edge.
Say that I have used G here I'll use H okay, I'll use edge,
uh, which is not defined.
Okay? I have to run this. Okay?
So now what I can do is I can use some of the reduction
or some, uh, operations, like yeah,
it is showing some, okay?
So it'll, what it'll do is it'll add all the
elements in my tensor
and return, whatever is the total sum of this.
So what I, what we have done is created a tensor
and reduced that tensor into one single scaler, same thing,
the it being represented in,
into this particular scaler, right?
So now, uh, I can use all other, uh, statistical, uh,
things like I can use mean for that matter, okay?
I can use mean of edge.
So then it'll give what is the mean
of all these values, right?
I can use towards dot median also like mean,
I can use always median.
So this will gimme the median of this.
Fine, I can use the, uh, other, other, uh,
statistical measure also, like torch max,
I can give the max in, in h what is the maximum value?
0.9, I guess. So 0.9849 has come.
I can also get the minimum value.
So all those, uh, things you can easily get. Uh, sorry.
So let me write min first
h many other operations you can do, obviously.
So minimum value was 0.2 9, 2 4, same thing.
It is printing here. So all these things are called
reduction operation
because, uh, a big tensiles, maybe two cross three sides
or 10 cross 10 sides, you're reducing it to one scaler
or some other form, which is,
which is called reduction, right?
So it is not in the same dimension.
Now you're reducing it to some other dimension.
So that is called the reduction. Okay?
So this, these are some of the operations which we can do
with the tensor next operation.
One question here, sir. Yeah, yeah, please, please.
So, uh, uh, can, for example, we have 3, 2, 3 mattresses.
Mm-hmm. So can we reduce it to 2, 2 3
or something like that function?
We can do that, but that, that is something called
reshaping, uh, that will,
that will see, I'll show you that one.
Yes. Uh, if you can, if you want, you can
reshape your metrics into some other side.
That is what, what exactly
what you said. I'll show you that.
Sure. Yeah. No, excuse me, sir. Have a moment.
Yeah, please, please. Uh, sir, uh, first of all,
this tensor flow, uh, sorry, uh, why, what is the difference
between arch and tensor glosson when
to use arch and when to use 10?
You have not attended last session?
Uh, no sir. I did not know that
Because that was the first thing
what we discussed in the last session.
Okay. Sorry. Maybe, uh, Sunil, let, uh, him, uh,
watch the video and then come back for the Yes.
Yes, sir. Sorry sir. My, my request is no, all
of you kindly put your name rather than this coded name
like, uh, Pakistanis spy agent.
So
We were asked to do this.
I think attendance is being tracked with this id.
That's why we have all changed recently. Actually, no,
You put the something no on sharp name.
Sure, sure. Mda.
Yeah. Okay. We were worried that we'll record the
or not. Yeah, we can do that.
No, because we want to know your names.
No, we'll update, we'll update.
The whole friend is talking to us
and, uh, thank you.
Yes, sir. So, uh, okay,
so like we have worked with the one dimension, as I said,
you can easily extend all those mathematical operation even
with the higher dimensions.
There is no problem with that.
So for example, suppose I will use this one.
Uh, this is one tensor where, uh, a is another tensor,
and uh, B is some, uh, say that another tensor say that
for, for the same dimension.
So then same in the same way, how we have done the metrics,
or sorry, mathematical operation with the one, uh,
one dimension tenor.
We can do with the this two cross three,
also one plus A plus B file two, it'll actually add those.
So let me just show you what is A and B plus
and then A plus B.
Yeah. So it has added element wise, uh, those rather than,
so you can use any, any dimension for that matter.
It, it doesn't matter.
And, uh, because I'm using random numbers, so I have given
what is the low and high value,
otherwise it might not be required as well.
If you want to create your own tensor of your, your values,
whatever you want to set, you can do that.
All those things are possible. So
likewise, all those operations, A minus V
or a aim two B, everything is possible.
And these operations, at least these multiplication,
maybe in the next class when we will talk about the
mathematical understanding of a neuron, that
how exactly a neuron works mathematically
there the weights are being multiplied with the biases.
So where it will be one metrics like this, uh, sorry, uh,
and uh, input will be another metrics will, uh, so
be the WX plus B, right?
So X is an input, W is a weight, B is a bias.
So all those things. So first we are going
to multiply my input with the weight
and then adding with the bias.
And all these are tens, all these at attends.
So we are going to use all these operations when we'll do
the neural networks
and we'll hand code it from in the,
I'll show you those things later.
So, uh, there are some other ways also,
although, so you can use say that.dot metrics
multiplication, okay?
Metrics, multiplication and uh, uh, shapes.
So yeah, here, uh, you know that right?
For the metrics multiplication, uh,
these shapes are not compatible.
Two, cross three and two cross three.
So this, this column of the first metrics should be the, uh,
the same dimension should be
for the rule of the next metrics.
So that is not com compatible. So it is not adding, right?
So if you, uh, sometimes, uh, if, if suppose this,
this will the problem accordingly,
you can just change this one
and then see, okay, whether it is
working or not, it'll work.
Obviously it'll work. So let me now show you that also.
Okay? So it is working in that case.
So some of these things you just have to keep in mind
and uh, uh, you can also work with the uh,
uh, for that matter.
You can work with a comparison.
Uh, say that, uh, I'll use here two cross three
to show you some more operations,
like whether A is greater than B.
So it is telling false,
so it is again checking element wise A and B.
So this is A, and this is B element wise.
So greater than B means five is
greater than eight, it is false.
So it has written false two is greater than nine,
false nine is greater than six.
True. So six is greater than nine,
false six is greater than one,
true two is greater than nine false.
So you can see that there are two true
or rest, all values are false.
Similarly, you can do any other kind
of comparison also if it is required.
And if you wish, you can also check whether they're equal
or not all are false because none
of the values are equal and so on.
So all these things also you can easily do
and very easily with the tensiles, you can uh,
use some special functions as well.
For example, uh, you can find what is uh, uh,
log of all the value, whatever you want.
For example, you can use torch dot, you can say log
and you can pass a.
Okay, A is tensor.
Just now we have seen A is this particular value
and it has calculated what is log of five, log
of two element twice again,
and it has gi given us the new metrics with this.
Okay? So all these things that you can also use say that
to taught, um, exponential.
So this, the expon, this operation also we can do
and many other square route you can use many other
operations you can use for that.
Yeah, yeah, please, please.
Can we use a transpose of metrics? Transpose of metrics,
Uh, yeah, definitely transpose.
Also we can do, there is a, uh, I think that,
And one more do sir.
Ah, this cross product and dot product of the metrics.
Uh, can we done, uh, are we having any different function?
No, no, we have that one at least for dot product.
Uh, you can, you directly dot,
Okay, mass is cross, right?
Yes, yes. So map mathematics, multiplication is across,
that's why it had given the error when the two dimensions
were not compatible, right?
But with the dot product, uh, tot.dot,
this is a function and uh, obviously I have to give A
and B, uh, 1D tens are expected, but 2D, okay, so 2D
and 2D tensiles are given.
So any 1D tensiles, which I have used,
so I can create that one no problem for that matter,
if it is required, and I can do the dot product for
between those two, right?
For even. Uh, so this is possible even
for the higher dimension,
but then, uh, uh, uh, we have
to change a little bit and it is possible.
So those things are possible.
Sometimes, uh, dot products
and all you have the direct, uh, functions
for that one, right?
There is no problem with the 1D.
It can easily, you can use with a higher dimension,
you can change a little bit and then you can use it.
Maybe direct function is, uh, may not be
there. You can change.
Sir. Is there any command where we can come to know
what functions are there available?
So, okay, based on our requirement, we can choose
Direct, correct? But, but for
that you have to go to the towards,
uh, documentation.
Uh, okay, sir. That is what you have to go with this
and you will get, everything is there in this documentation.
You just have to go there and check that, okay?
In this particular documentation.
So no, nothing, any, any no inbuilt commands like help us
something American list on all the
touch functions. Is it anything like that?
I not, I'm not aware. Okay. It might be there.
You please check that. Okay.
Uh, I'm, because there are multiple, uh, modules are there.
I'm just talking right now about the basic torch functions.
Going further, you have the neural network
wave first functions.
So that is stored in some other kind of,
uh, uh, some other library.
Uh, so we have a lot of things.
You see that, all these things, okay?
So with the tos also, we have multiple things.
We have, uh, multiple things,
and inside everything you will have the
hundreds of functions.
So one single command, I'm not sure how to know that.
Just check that one. Okay?
Okay, sir. Now one, a couple of more things, uh,
I'll try to conclude in the next five minute.
So although there are endless
functions which I cannot cover even, I don't know,
but then, uh, uh, couple of things,
two more things which might be of help for us.
Uh, that is what I want to discuss.
For example, suppose I have, uh, tensor
torch dot tensor, um,
to cross three, same thing.
And n also, uh,
do tensor to cross these.
Say that these two are the tensor.
I have, uh, sorry, I I'll use rant, okay?
Otherwise I have to write the values
that these two are the tens I have.
So you can check and see what I, what has come here.
These two are the tens, what I have now, uh, usually
what happened, what I have shown you so far,
if I do this M plus n what has happened is,
uh, you've got the answer.
There is no problem. But then, uh, it's something which is,
uh, addition of these two.
So what has happened in the backend
to store this particular tensor,
two dimensional tensor or metrics.
You can say that in the memory, maybe another 48 bytes,
if it is a post float value, uh, eight bytes for each
six value, so total 48 bytes must be allocated.
Then, then we are, we can see this particular thing, right,
which is because the m is still this,
that there is no change in name.
And then M plus N is a new metrics which we have got,
which we have to store somewhere in the memory,
and then only we can visualize, we can use for any purpose
what we want many times in the deep learning
that is really costly.
This particular operation is really costly
because may, uh, with this, this, I mean to an operation,
we will be doing very frequently, right?
Multiplication between the metricses, uh,
input and weight and so on.
So every time we don't want to create a new metrics
because right now you see the metrics in two cross three
size, but in reality, you may have the metrics called,
uh, 2000 cross, 1000 size,
where 2000 is a dimension of the input
and 1000 in the number
of neurons in the next here and layer.
Now in such a huge metrics, when you want to multiply,
many times there will be requirement that, okay,
you don't want to store that one in another metrics
because again, it is going to require a huge, huge,
huge space, right?
And that's where this in place operation come
into the picture in place.
So what it does, basically, if you want to add M
and n, instead of adding directly, which requires another,
um, huge space, you can use m dot add.
And there is something, this underscore,
this underscore is the indication that you are in placing
whatever inside the m Now it'll be replaced by this
whatever operation we want to perform now.
So this will also result you the same answer.
What you can see here, M plus N and M plus N,
but now if you will check
what is MM is the same value,
what you have just added,
and it is not the earlier older value of m which
with you have initialized.
Now, this is what I wanted to actually explain.
So many times, this is very helpful in the neural network
where you are dealing with millions of weights, okay?
Thousands of weights, saving the space,
saving the time is, is very important.
And, uh, you, you should utilize this one.
So this is one operation which I want to, wanted to explain.
Now at last, uh, just want to give you, uh,
something called GPU
versus, uh, CPU.
Uh, what is the difference
and how much it, uh, uh,
how much time it takes if you use the GPU
or uh, say that CPU.
So for that one, uh, I, same thing.
Everything will be available with you.
I'll share this slide,
but I'm just copying for now this, yeah, so I,
this is the code where
what I have done is I have created two tensiles,
like I have been creating right now,
but the now tensile size is little bigger.
See 10,000 crossed 10,000 randomly in the slides
between zero and one, right?
That's why this grant function.
Before that, I'm checking that whether I have, uh, coulda
or not GPU availability or not.
So first time I am doing the CPU multiplication, okay?
This, this will do that, uh, CPU multiplication, okay?
And then it'll show you source the result,
and then the same metrics multiplication.
What I will do, you, I will do using the GPU, okay?
If available. So that's why this, this, uh,
first time checking here, could I is available or not,
and then it'll use the coda.
Otherwise it was using the device W device, okay?
So this is the code which will do the two type two
multiplication, same multiplication, one with the CPU one
with the GPU, and then it'll show us the time.
You see that every time when I'm doing the multiplication,
I'm starting the time ending the time that
how much time it has taken for that multiplication.
And same thing here also with the GPU start
and end in between, I'm doing the mat multiplication.
So this is what I'm going to do. I'll, I will run that.
So yes, could kuda is available, GP is available.
Tesla T four. Now CPU computation is taking some time.
You see that device for W is CPU device for X is CPU.
So because 10,000 cross 10,000, which is realistic
in the world of LLM, what we are living, okay?
It's not something which is people have not worked
on, right?
So you see that it takes some time when it has
to multiply such a huge metrics
on the CPU taken 25 seconds time,
I don't know whether 25 second, 25.7 1, 4 3, 6 6,
and when it has run on the GPU, see 0.4.
See the huge difference, okay? See the huge difference.
So in reality, if suppose you build a machine, uh, sorry,
deep learning model, right?
Run it on the CPU, then run it on the GPU,
and it is a huge network like LLM,
this difference is a hundred times
and more than that also,
that's why the GPU is always recommended
for the deep learning task.
And all you can see with the one one simple operations
also, this is the difference.
You, you have observed the one last thing, someone asked
that, okay, can we, how to reshape, uh, reshape, uh, so
that I will do and then I will stop.
So I will again, instead of typing, I will simply,
uh, do this one.
So torch, yeah, this line say
that this line will create the tensor.
We have already seen how to create the tensor,
so arrange function, okay?
And it'll give us the value between zero to 12
ending at 12 step sizes.
One, same thing, nothing different here,
but now, uh, if I want to, uh,
reduce it in some other form, some other form, so
I can do it, and that's where we, we utilize this, uh,
reshape, uh, uh, reshape different different function, uh,
reshape function like view is one such function.
So now I know that there are 12 elements inside this, right?
12 values are there inside this particular tensor.
Now, how I want to arrange this one,
that is the call i, I can take.
I want three cross four.
That means three rows and four column.
It'll result in that 12.
So see that now the same values,
same tensor is now reduced in the, uh,
one dimensional tensor is now gone
for the three cross four size.
I can also do something like that, two cross six. Okay?
So it'll give now two rows and six column.
I can also do six cross two for, for if, if we wish fine.
But if I try to do six cross three for, for,
for the matter t that it has told
that shape six cross three is invalid for the input size 12.
Now it knows that the input size has only 12 elements.
So you can, you have to put the numbers in such a way
that you are using only those 12 thing,
not the something which is beyond
that 12 cross one is also fine.
So that this is called almost the transpose, that row
tensor now is converted into the column.
So this is, this is, this is, this is how it is.
You can do that one, right? Okay, so let me stop here.
Maybe, uh, now I,
if you have any quick question you can take
otherwise maybe director can take over
and explain some of the
In, in, in place.
When we are doing, sir, it's changing the value of M. Yes.
Yeah. So is there any option to retain the values?
Then don't then, uh, see if you want to retain the value,
then there is no problem retain the value in the sense,
uh, m value.
Yeah. Original metrics, values,
Uhhuh, then it was simple, right?
The same thing I did. So MI had
and also I had, I did want,
I don't don't want any change in M so I have added this one.
I can store it somewhere else, CS.
So if space is not a problem, this is fine.
Yes. After doing this operation, m and N is in intact
and you are getting the addition of that also,
which is in S right?
But then if you don't want that space
and you want to optimize,
which is which will be the requirement in many cases,
then you can in please. Yeah.
Yes, thank you. Yes.
One question, sir. Yes.
Uh, related with that, uh, could I
and device whatever, we explicitly use that Yeah.
On c, p and GP, right? Correct.
So if we are either of that, if we are not using by default,
it'll be, it'll be used whatever the
runtime we have set, right? Correct,
Correct, correct.
So by default it was always using the GP only
because we had set it as GPU, you remember in the start,
Yes, yes. But then
I explicitly said that no use the CPU.
So for this operation, it has used the CPU. Yeah.
Otherwise by default, whatever you will set, it'll use.
Yes, sir. Yeah, please,
Sir. That, uh,
m in, uh, in place Y is there now, sir. Yeah.
Yeah. Whenever, uh, let's say if it is in a loop,
whenever they are, uh, we are getting added,
that latest value will be getting stored
in M, right, sir? Mm-hmm.
Hmm. Yes. Yes, if you will.
And many times it is required, uh, in the, in the we.
We'll talk about more about that anytime it is required.
Oh, thanks.
Start for five, uh, storage.
Do we need to always use, uh, a lab notebook or somewhere?
No, no, no. I mean, you can use it anywhere.
I mean, you can even use this, uh, vs code, um,
and you can start doing it here also.
Uh, but many, uh, if you're using any other, you just have
to make sure that torch is installed or not.
That's all torch
you have to install, that's all.
Nothing else anywhere you can use,
Sir. Uh,
how do you, for the, uh, sorry.
Um, uh, for the, um, condensation that you have mentioned,
will it be explained in the coming sessions or,
because we may encounter contestation
for our projects and all.
Correct. So that will definitely be a part of LLM,
but I am afraid that we will cover that part in this, uh,
uh, deep learning course or not.
I'll see that if it is, if time will be there, we'll see
that other RLM, you will definitely have that one
because that's where there is a requirement of that.
Yeah.
Okay.
Any other query? Uh, sir, I like, uh,
can you show any functions
regarding this back publications that we
Will do this partial derivation?
Yes, we will do everything.
Uh, there is something called torch auto grad. Okay.
Now auto grad is meant for that.
Uh, so it'll, uh, so here, I, I,
I mentioned that some of the most important operations,
which we are going to hear it is not mentioned,
but I'll show you that one and maybe one more class,
and we will be there where I'll show you how to use the TAs
for the back propagation, how it calculate the gradient
and all, everything will see.
Okay? Thank you. Yeah,
Sorry. If we want
to use something other than Google call, so how
will will we be able to use this GPUs and all?
Yes, it, no, but the point is if you're using your local
system, you have to make sure that in your local system,
GP is available and you can check this using
this particular line.
So whatever Id you have you try this one,
it'll tell you whether the GPU is available or not.
Okay? Yeah, but you can use it.
That's not an issue
because nowadays whatever computing, at least some,
some GP was there.
I think so, yeah. Alright, then I'll stop here.
Maybe, uh, sir,
Uh, yeah, yeah, I'll be, I present sir or whatever.
Yeah. I, I, no, I will present.
Okay.
Hope my slides are visible.
Not yet. Not yet, sir. Not yet.
Okay.
Not visible
Or not yet, sir?
Oh, no. At least sharing is visible. No,
No, sir. It is
not.
Okay. Let share
how it should be.
Okay. Still the same. No sir. It is.
Yeah, it is loading now, sir.
Maybe my mission is slow.
Yes, it's Is it coming?
I mean, it is, uh, it's showing
that has started screen. Uh, now it's,
Yeah, now it's, yeah. Is it changing?
Yes. Yes, it's changing.
Okay. So, uh,
see in the last session we gave overview about this deep
learning, uh, course
and what we are planning, also evaluation plan.
And then, uh, Dr.
Sunil took over and, uh,
started introducing Arch compared with TensorFlow.
Now extended in this session also
because arch is one of the mainly user toolkit, uh,
especially when you are, uh,
doing your deep learning related works.
My suggestion will be, uh, you can take it
as an humble request.
You people watch both the sessions, last session type,
ACH related information, and also today's session.
And do the hands-on by yourself, so then know you will, uh,
really, uh, start following things
because in the following, hands-on session,
unless you have comfortness with ach,
so you will lag behind.
So that's where I just wanted to tell that.
So now to start the course, um, uh, see
as mentioned in the course plan, uh,
since deep learning models are, uh, know, um,
historically connected to the concept
of artificial neural networks, um, we'll briefly present
some basic concepts
or terminologies in neural networks, which are useful
for better understanding of the deep learning concepts.
These are not an exhaust to
'cause typically in some universities, uh,
of course nowadays may not be,
but earlier when we studied neural networks was when
deep learning was not there.
Neural networks was there.
Semester long course here, we are not going to do that.
Just only one or one session to introduce you, one
or two sessions to introduce to the important
of the neural networks.
See, generally, uh, when
we are discussing about neural networks are more
specifically we call it as a artificial neural networks
and their recent avatars deep learning models,
we equate it to human brain.
So I'm not going to explain this figure,
but I just want the shape to be, you know,
reflected in your minds that
there is a miscommunication that we are trying to,
we have derived some theory behind, um, human brain
and trying to put as a computational model.
It is only a, a, a reference
for the development of these neural
networks and deep learning models.
From a computing field point of view,
both the neural networks
and deep learning models are computational models whose
structure and functioning are inspired by the
structure and functioning of human drive.
So accordingly, both neural networks
and deep learning models only mimic some
of the cognitive functions,
but it'll not will be a no, a digital twin,
our real time model of the brain or something.
So that is what we all have to, um,
because other ways we are, um,
what I want to say, uh,
demeaning, or I'm not getting a proper word,
we are underestimating the power of our human brain.
Only a simple scratched knowledge of structure
and functioning of human brain in spice
coming up with computational models.
Okay, so that is all, uh, I want to say,
what is the structure point of view?
Structure? Point of view. If you take human brain, it has,
uh, billions of neuro cells
that the basic neuro cell is called as a biological neuron.
That is a fundamental cell,
and billions of them put together
forms this moss, human brain moss,
and, uh, uh,
so the basic element is the biological neuron.
And another important point from a structure point
of view is all these billions of neurons are
arranged in a layered manner, starting from lowest layer
to the up highest layer, okay?
So that, uh, so billions of neurons,
which are basic computing elements
arranged in several layered manner,
and that is equivalent to, if you want
to bring a computer science terminology,
a computing terminology, it is equal to parallel
and a distributed processing.
When from a sensory mechanism, you ex exit the lowest layer
of the human brain, which has, you know, say millions
of neurons that excitation,
parallelly fed into all available neurons there.
And each of those neurons are fairly independent.
They work independently and produce the output.
And when that output comes up,
that moves up in the next layer
and goes on essentially the parallel
and distributed processing, layered manner of organization
and parallel and distributed processing
are the two abilities that are taken from,
uh, human brain functioning.
And after that, the computing models that all we are going
to study as part of neural networks
and deep learning are only fully mathematical concepts
or computational models
that we have developed based on convenience.
Beyond that, no, there is not much from human
brain structure point of view.
Billions of basic computing elements are there,
which are called as biological neurons,
basic computing cells.
And that is one thing we are borrowing to come up with
what are called artificial neurons
as basic computing elements.
Next thing is all these, uh,
basic computing elements like neurons are arranged in
layered manner to form a network,
which either it can be neural network
or deep learning model, and that is a structure part of it.
Whereas when it comes to the functioning part,
human brain works in parallel
and distributed manner, as I told,
an excitation from a sensor mechanism is fed into a large
number of neurons at any point of time,
and each neuron processes based on the input received
and produce stop that is the functioning parallel,
distributed processing, basic computing element is neuron
arranged in a layered manner.
That is structure functioning is,
um, parallel and distributed process.
That's all that these two things are taken this concept from
the, um, then from the theory of brain
and people have come up with the computational models.
That's all beyond this.
We should not read too much into human brain.
Why people turned towards biological neural networks was
a robustness and fault tolerance, for example,
parallel to neural networks are deep learning models.
What are other computational models?
If you take like, uh, know, um, any other, uh,
computational models which are there at that point of time,
um, like any statistical model or anything
or stochastic model, people give input to one
input node and the processing happens through that model,
and output comes single input, single output.
At that point, due to any reason
that input node is not working, the whole system fails.
Whereas in this case, since at any layered way,
the input is given to a large number of computing elements,
even if some of the computing elements are not
functioning properly, are dead.
The other compute through other computing elements
that are parallel pass through which information flows
to the higher layers.
And accordingly, we get this robustness and fault tolerance.
The decay of the nerve cells
will not affect the performance significantly.
Then this is one, one motivating path to,
for people to derive computational models inspired
by structuring and functioning of the one point.
The next part, next part is the flexibility. Flexibility.
See, one of the hallmark, uh, uh, characteristics
of human brain is they can easily adjust
to the new environment, operating environment without much,
uh, uh, you know, relining of your brain for that purpose.
A simplest example is, you know,
if you are your vision system through eyes, when you want
to see new environment, see at all environment,
there will be different elimination levels.
All those things you don't really creep about.
No, oh, I can't see this person, uh,
because, uh, he's in a low illuminated area
or something partially excluded.
Similarly, if I take speech, no, we listen
to speech in a recording studio also
and in outside nice environmental, of course the amount of,
um, learning, uh, comfortness may be vary,
but we still, we don't cry too much.
That is what we call flexibility.
Visavis is computational models.
What used to say demonstrate is they work well
for the trained condition that means a specific environment.
But beyond that, uh, no, any new environment it goes, it uh,
it, it uh, um, what we call, uh,
fails miserably because it has not seen that environment.
So then the variety of data, so the,
the par the human brain capabilities, I think all
of these you can equate with your daily experience.
We can deal with the data which is very noisy, um, no, uh,
very fuzzy, which is not exact replica
of the previous instances you have seen.
That is the, um, no, no, no
hallmark address of human brain.
That means to say, suppose you see the face of a person
very close to you sitting next to, uh, across the table
or the same person you see in a crowd where the,
the facial image will be a very small portion
of the whole scene you are watching,
but still you are able to, that is the ability
of human brain, variety of data and collective competition.
So, um, it,
it performs many operations in parallel, okay,
and in a distributed manner.
So these are some of the important, uh, uh, characteristics
of human brain that motivated people to come up
with computational models, which are inspired
by the structure and functioning of human brains.
If you consider now the basic working
of a biological neuron, a biological neuron looks like this,
where there is a cell body
and the cell body is connected, extended with a lot
of hairy like structures, which are called as dendrites.
And through dendrite,
they're like input wire for this cell body.
Through this, through this dendrites
or the input wire, um, the, uh,
uh, the information
or excitation from the neighborhood, uh,
neurons are received into the cell body, okay?
And the, the, the biochemical activity that happens
inside this cell body, uh, is the summation
of all the inputs that is received from so many dendrites
or hair-like structures we have is a weighted combination of
that happens, and then it is compared with a threshold
that is the resting potential
of the chemical substance within the cell body.
When once that weighted summation value exceeds the
threshold, we say the biological neuron files,
when it fires the, the,
the weighted somewhat value, uh, exceeding
that threshold is ed
through a non-linear operation.
When it fires, it gives a pulse like thing,
which is a non-linear operation that is maybe could
by a function called NEF function.
And accordingly you get an output from the neuron.
This is the yellow line, which is shown is
the output from the neuron, and it goes through this output.
Again, this output, even though it comes through, uh,
we call it as axon, even though it comes out through one
hair-like structure, that again gets split into many output,
uh, this one, and
through this it goes into the neighborhood, uh,
neurons, okay?
And um,
what happens is support the output, which is going
through these output junctions, which are called
as synaptic junctions.
In case of, uh, no human brain studies
repeatedly the output go through specific, uh, junction.
Repeatedly it is impacting that, uh, junction.
Then we can say that junction, uh,
increases in strengths in weight with the time.
Otherwise, if that, uh, junction is not getting ex exit,
then slowly it weakens that junction
and those are called as synaptic junctions.
Now, this is the basic cooperation of any biological neuron
where you have said no, uh, billions
of neurons are there out of that.
If I take any neuron
and say how it works, this is how it works.
It collects the inputs from a neighborhood,
takes a weighted combination, compares
with the resting potential if it exceeds the resting
potential, we say the biological neuron fires when it fires
and nonlinear output comes, that is modeled
by a function ef,
and the nonlinear output will further get spread out
through his output neuron through millions
of neurons in the next layer.
Okay? Are including the same layer,
which are there in the neighborhood,
and that junctions are
around which this output gets dissipated.
Those are called a synaptic junction
and a repeated firing of that part,
any particular junction increases the strength.
If it is not fired, then it becomes,
it weakens with the time.
Okay? So that's what will happen by this is
what they have told how a biological neuron works,
and that is being converted into an equivalent computational
model on the computer, which is, see this, all this
through dendrites X one, x two, et cetera, x,
and our inputs, which are coming into the cell body are
shown as in, in, in one, two, et cetera.
In that means to say there are any inputs
and there is a weighted combination of that,
that is summation shows weighted combination.
Another point we have to show is this, these junctions
will have some the synaptics junction weight,
and those are multiplied by the link weight
that we will see later link weight, because those are, see,
because this, I'm showing it as synaptic junction,
these can be a synaptic junction for the previous, uh, um,
neurons, which is coming out that, so that is where
that weight will happen, weighted summation,
and there is a bias, resting potential is given by the bias
in mathematics, we call it as theta.
This weighted summation is compared with the bias
and, uh, weighted combination minus bias is
equal to zero means is exactly equal to bias value,
and it goes beyond that.
It becomes fir and that is possibly a nonlinear activity
that is, that
and is weighted comm, uh, combination minus bias is called
as activation value.
Activation value when it fights
that it results in an nonlinear activity of that
and that results in the output, which is fed to the,
and this is the basic computing element, uh,
which has been inspired by studying the functioning of
the biological neuron.
And this basic computing element, uh,
is used in the neural networks.
And the same concept has been used in the deep learning
models also, except that, you know, the nature
of the output function may change depending on which type
of, whether we are using a neural network
or a deep learning model.
And accordingly, this is the terminology that we are taking
to the deep learning, uh, course that the concept
of basic computing element,
the basic computing element is the, this,
this lower one is an artificial neuron inspired
by the functioning of structure
and functioning of the biological neuron.
Um, so any, any doubt or clarification here to any of you?
Uh, sir, I have one question, sir.
Since we have derived this artificial neural network based
on the biological neural networks,
we have the input and output according
This is no, no, no, no. This
is not network. This is the only one neuro one network.
Yes, yes, sir. Exactly. So, uh, to one neuron, sir.
So we, we are able to, uh, go for equivalent model
of input and output.
So we have this middle layer
where we call this myelin sheet.
So I have read an article, this myelin sheet, it's, uh,
connecting between this, uh, neuron input
and output, uh, to efficiently
and speed up the data transmission theoretical impulses.
So equal mapping in neural network. Uh, what is that?
Uh, entities, sir, of myam sheet.
Uh, here there's no, uh, equal
and can you please repeat that?
I was just thinking something else. Sorry,
Sir. This, yes, sir. Myam
sheet helps in, uh, transmission
of the electrical impulse from the input
to output in a quick manner and an efficient manner, sir.
Uh, so though we are able to go
for equivalent mathematical model,
but what is the entity which represents this myelin
sheet model, sir?
Actually this myelin sheet no entity is representing,
it's just an output of the neuron.
Just an output no of the neuron here, okay?
This is not, there is a long way
or something in the output neuron.
Just to elaborate that concept that are shown here,
you just collect the output at this point,
there is no delay or anything there,
Okay? Okay, sir.
Sure, sir. There's no delay. Okay.
And see weighted summation exceeding the bias results in a
non-linear activity inside the cell,
that non-linear activity,
the firing is a non-linear activity just to account
for the nonlinear activity.
This is used. Okay?
Yeah, any other doubt?
So see, when we have moved from
shallow neural networks to deep neural networks
or deep learning models, the basic computing element,
that neuron remains same.
There's no change in that basic working principle.
Accordingly, implementation also the only change, the choice
of the output function.
That changes from neural network concept
to deep learning concept that we will see as we go.
Okay? So, uh, the basic unit
of the biological neural network is called biological neuron
or neuro cell, cell body
or soma, where nucleus is located, this is the left part,
this is called the nucleus axon is a long fiber.
So this is a long fiber, which is going okay from cell body
and branches in strands connect
to many other neurons in the synaptic juncture.
Okay? Dendrites are large number of five few thousands
of them receive information from other cells.
That is this all dendrites synaptic junctions can
be on the dendrite server.
So these, the axon which branches out into all these, uh,
output, uh, small, small nodes, no,
they're called a synaptic injections.
That is where repeated firing
of a particular junction increases in the strength
and those gets mapped into weight parameters in the neural
network and the deep learning model.
Okay? So how when a neuron functions transmission
of a signal, it's a, a complex chemical process, then
specific transmitter substances are released
at this synt injection.
So what exactly happens?
This is like a biochemical process when it fires means, uh,
no, uh, um, um, uh,
um, transmitter substance is released around that fiber,
but it's nothing but the effect is
to rise our lower electrical potential inside the body
of the receiving cell.
Okay? Potential reaches a threshold
and electrical activity in the form
of sharp pulse is generated and we say the neuron is fired.
Electrical segments of fixed strength
and duration are sent down the accident.
So, um, then the,
the cell body will act as a summing device.
The synaptic junction, which is repeatedly triggered
from the output of the axon that we call it as pro
or post-synaptic neuron,
will grow in strength while others gradually weaken.
Now, strength of the synaptic junction will get modified
continuously and um,
and that we call it as a synaptic plasticity.
That is a phenomenon which is now where the, uh,
some junctions repeatedly fired, will grow in strength,
which are not fired.
They will get weakened in strength.
So that is a very hallmark of human brain
junctions, synaptic junction.
That is all, no, when we are repeatedly practicing certain
activities, uh, those gets registered well
and it becomes a go to an autonomous mode.
But if you're not refreshing, you'll forget
after that there's nothing to worry.
That is the very purpose of, uh,
synaptic plasticity associated with human brain.
Okay? And, uh, uh, I think, um, uh,
I will stop it here because other elements will do it.
Uh, so just you refer to this
however biological neuron works.
I think that is why in the end, whether you
remember this terminologist or not, since, uh,
is relevant at all, but only we should appreciate
how people came up with this computational model, uh,
to implement on a compute.
That's it. Rest part.
I will do it in the next class already. 10 35.
Yeah. Any questions there?
Who is the ta? Sunil?
Hello, sir? Ah, yes, please.
Hi. Yes, sir, I'm Vimal.
Ah, Vimal. Uh, sir, uh, these slides here
to upload.
No, in the folder, sir.
Uh, I'm uploading the only sir
and also created today summary.
Also
Take it, um, I put my slides in the chat box also.
Then you can also download and upload. Okay, sir? Okay, sir.
Yeah, so just to summarize now, please just, uh,
a very simple phenomenon, how a biological neuron works
and how it is converted into a competition model.
Use it for the field of computing.
You can just, uh, refresh it rest
of the part we'll see in the next session.
I'll stop it here. Yes? Yes, sir. Thank you, sir.
Thank you all. Thank you, sir. Yes, sir. Thank you.
Thank you, sir. Sir, thank you. Thank you, sir.
Thank you, sir. Thank you, sir. You sir.
Thank you.